look mr. better a lot has changed in
nearly a decade since Bioshock 1 first
launched but while our world is
constantly in flux the worlds of rapture
and Columbia are just as atmospheric
haunting and oppressive as you remember
it
I went hands-on with the remastered
versions of Bioshock 1 Bioshock 2 and
BioShock Infinite and it felt like I had
been transported back to the first time
I've played the games the first Bioshock
is the crown jewel of this collection
and 2k has gone back and spent a lot of
time with it sharpening it up and
generally making it feel more modern the
remasters graphics won't blow you away
but it's hard to see rough edges in
signs of age and bioshock's gorgeous art
shines through with this new coat of
paint
2k doesn't need to make a 9 year old
game look incredible according to 2016
standards but it does need to do enough
that you aren't distracted from the
beautiful and entrancing world of
rapture and at that it succeeds
in addition the far more action in
BioShock Infinite is also included in
the collection if you own the game on PC
you won't notice much of a difference
this version of infinite is essentially
the PC version but if you played it on a
console like me the remaster shows that
infinite is at least graphically the
pinnacle of the Bioshock series even
though it's been more than three years
since BioShock Infinite launched the
game looks almost like it could be
released tomorrow Columbia is gorgeous
full of vibrant colors and minut detail
and the constantly moving Cloud City
looks just as interesting as ever
infinite still plays great as well with
fun fast-paced combat Bioshock 1
received the most work in the collection
but infinite got just enough of a
remaster that it's well worth returning
to
if an overhauled Bioshock and a better
looking infinite arts enough Bioshock
the collection also comes with remaster
Bioshock 2 I didn't play much of
Bioshock 2 but I played enough to verify
that it looks considerably better than
its original console versions if you're
like me and never actually played
Bioshock 2 this is the best way to try
it especially since it comes in a pack
with Bioshock 1 and infinite daddy was
sleeping for such a long time and
Eleanor has missed you find her gnocchi
Oh better as it brings all of these
pieces together Bioshock the collection
is shaping up to be a fantastic monument
to the series it's much more than simply
a remaster of a beloved title it's a
preservation effort a way to experience
a series that meant so much to so many
people and that influenced future games
in so many ways and it doesn't stop
there
every piece of single-player bioshock
content is included in this and Bioshock
1 even features director's commentary
with game director Ken Levine and lead
artist Sean Robertson remasters get a
lot of flack these days and not without
reason
but Bioshock the collection includes
enough content that it's well worth the
price to return the prettier but just as
haunting versions of rapture and
Columbia we can see late coming from his
daily
enemy he's still breathing it's alright
I know he'll be an angel soon
you all right boy